now I think that two force and a guy one
for England
Senegal have found their rhythm
this has been a World Cup surprise
results so how about one more
England will start as deserved favorites
for the African Champions and not to be
underestimated
last year Senegal was
every time we had very big players but
uh no titles so this year we managed to
have our first African Champion so I
think this year's that grows the the
confidence on on the team and on the
country
Senegal without their star player the
former Liverpool are now Bayern Munich
forward sadio Mane he's missed the
tournament through injury
but they've still scored goals and from
all areas of the side
this is what I said to the boys play the
football you know how to play you're
here it's not the
uh it's not a surprise because uh we are
some part of Africa so we are here so
now it's good time for for the players
to to write their story in this in this
tournament
many of the Senegal team play in England
including Chelsea's eduard Mendy and
kaladu kulabali and watford's Ismail I
saw but this will be the first time that
the two sides have met in a major
tournament a place in the quarterfinals
is at stake alastip Uncle Sky News in
Qatar